scarlet usb okay i think that's working
let's see
put this mic here
okay
what up guys oh is that too loud what up
guys i'm a little quieter what up guys
what
what up
what up
okay
what up guys i think that's good tell me
is that audio level okay welcome to the
just pearly things youtube channel today
i'm going to be reacting
to content
live on the stream
so let me pull up my youtube
i'm back in this room because i'm still
gonna react to my own content in this
room
but
okay let's see
what is big
in
youtube right now let me see what i want
to watch
um
okay
um
[Music]
let's see
um let's do it sound fresh and fit maybe
[Music]
some suggestions in the chat i feel like
some people dm me stuff recently
but i forget you guys know how it
is oh
the tinder swindler that'll get taken
down for copyright
but i would love to watch that but i'm
not trying to get this live struck
um
what i want to do i started
i started
this very randomly i was just like i
haven't live streamed in a couple days
sue taylor the find
i haven't watched him in a second
also if i make you mod okay i'll make
you moderator
okay
okay wait tell me
oh god that's very loud
tell me if you can hear this okay
oh also
guess what
speaking of andrew tate he agreed to
come on my show next time he's in london
so send donations so when he comes
i can give him the best equipment as you
guys know i'm doing a live show i
haven't announced this officially yet
but
the live show is going to be wednesday
at 8. okay let's see why we can't hear
it
wednesday at 8 00 p.m
uh gmt which is i think three eastern
time
okay let's
so it's not working huh
speakers
um
i wonder why this is
i know i know no audio i'm trying to fix
it
um
let me try moving my headphones over
here and seeing if this works
okay we're going to try this
okay
could be audio output
video device display capture okay let's
try it again tell me if you can hear
this
more validation guys we need to
compliment them more and we need
to treat them like the princesses they
are so let's take a listen
to what she has to say guys don't forget
to leave
your thoughts and your
can you guys hear that
it's being weird
yo what is going on guys why is this
slow is it in slow-mo or something
playback speed normal
what's good guys referral tell me could
you hear that before it's like sounding
weird on my end but i don't know why
yes you could hear the audio
but it's glitchy isn't it
okay wait let me try now guys hope
you're all doing well so on today's
episode we're going to be kicking it off
with this one right so pretty and stuff
so guys we're going to be taking a look
then they complain about the results
okay so you ready to go no i'm not ready
to go are you ready
okay so it's slightly loud
i can turn it down hold on
also is my audio okay on my because i
can turn up my voice if that makes it
better all right tell me tell me i look
cute women should be exempt from
absolutely everything during our periods
especially on the first and second day
we should not have to go to work go to
school leave our house we should always
be wearing sweatpants with fuzzy socks
wrapped in a heated blanket with a fresh
cup of tea because i should not have to
go about my day with my uterus
physically trying to claw its way
out of my body and neither should anyone
else
[Music]
hey uh you know you go out there you
take time off
your sound a little different yourself i
can hear you just fine just different
it's weird i switched to my laptop but
that shouldn't like change it you know
what i mean
like okay let me
just a little frustrating
just a little frustrating
up my volume a little bit okay
i mean i can move to my pc i just prefer
this like
angle a little bit better but i might
get a second monitor so i can just do it
in there i don't know we'll see
um
listen to a different video to see
because this audio just sounds weird
um
okay let me see what wi-fi am i on
because this wi-fi is so slow
yeah that's my wifi
so why on earth is this so slow because
i have very fast wi-fi
like very fast
um
okay let me
audio output capture
um okay let me
let me just see what default does
rise of sexes and derogatory music made
about them by male 1
irritating
irritating i go to my
[Music]
all right let me go back to this one and
see if that's better
it's just like glitchy for me
i know you guys hear
for me this is like straight glitch okay
um
on-ear headset external speakers
okay
[Music]
okay now i can hear it fine can you guys
hear this is the question
oh i know why
i figured it out i figured it out
i figured it out yes i got it
i got it oh my god dude [ __ ] ain't
[ __ ] but hoes and tricks yeah
dude oh my god i got it i got it i think
two life cruises
oh my gosh thank you thank you so much
for
for this um
okay thank you so much for the donation
it says let me see
vanity over biological responsibility
welcome to the modern world
thank you oh my god someone became a
member
dink
oh wait
oh my god i'm so dumb that was for
donovan's oh my god that is the dumbest
thing i've ever done
sorry i got confused um
it's okay ah
oh my god
okay
the
[Music]
react to my newest music video please
sir if i get copyrighted on this live i
am going to
okay what is your name
let's see
i swallowed equipment wrong
you have 34 subscribers
i can't
i can't do that right now um
okay
okay now what i want to watch
um
okay guys it's got to be a bigger video
that has views that's why i react to
stuff
unless it's just like
um plus i don't really do music
reactions live anymore because
i've had too many lives get like
copyright like taken down because of it
and i just don't want to mess with it
um
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen here he is the man
you came to oh yeah
okay let's see
oh my gosh what am i doing
okay
um
[Music]
truth or dare on a blind date this looks
like good thing to react to okay
bridgette she's so fine one of a kind
chocolate chips oh no
oh no trying to take you out check out
the whip in the parking lot let's go to
the next spot oh
[Music]
hi cocoa butter i have been single for
about six months now and i've had a lot
of trouble
i need your help finding a man 30 years
of trying hasn't worked
all right she's epiphany phase that's
where she's at i'm gonna help me find
asian yes i have a job
has to have a job
[Music]
the problem is i date um
that i really want like someone who is
fun cool
it's never an issue of being able to
meet people that's more so getting it to
stick
i don't have a type like i've dated all
type of women to be honest i'm just open
completely
oh hello hi
hi
nice to see you
oh wow this is sexy hi
i'm angel i'm davey nice to meet you
they're good looking that man
sir if you're watching this
you can have my number i'm just letting
you know you know respectfully sir mindy
josie nice to see you i'm bridget i'm
craig hi grant you can too sir
respectfully you know i mean like
respectfully i don't know if you guys
this truth or dare thing worked out
i wouldn't be a gentleman if i just
tried to go first okay
ladies first
oh my gosh uh rock paper scissors that's
how you want to do this right now
damn
if i was doing this this game
and this was my blind date oh my gosh
i'd be like i need to do this every time
scale of 1-10 how single are you and why
ten being very single how do you rate
singles you can definitely write how
single you are so very single means
there's nobody on your phone if i pull
out your phone
there is nobody people would be like i'm
single but like how single am i
lowkey's still talking my ex i look he
got like a little thing over here i'm a
10 all the way
because i stopped talking to people for
a little bit i got a little celibate all
right well i'm gonna do eight there we
go seven
six
five i'm a solid nine oh wow yeah what's
that one dash off uh i mean well you
might have a friends with benefits
somewhere just somewhere could you be in
a relationship
ship with someone that has bad sex
absolutely not if we're not compatible
on that level we're just friends it's a
two-player sport you know like if one
partner isn't up to par
i could kobe bryant that thing you know
that's actually very exciting i mean i
guess it depends it depends if they like
make up in other areas because like
other areas of my life uh sex is not the
end of life i mean the answer is
absolutely not i mean i understand that
it's a two-person thing or three person
or four percent final answer no how
about that no you could not be with
someone who has bad sex actually yes
because they can get better they can get
better funny that's how i feel i do not
date on sex i don't
think it's that important in a
relationship
but i'm also a girl so answer yes they
can get better mediocre sex whatever
bad sex
you probably can't dance or cook or
finesse it's just connected to so many
different things what's a flaw about you
that often ruins your relationships
what's a flaw about me that often ruins
my relationships
what would my ex-boyfriend say
nothing i did nothing wrong
yeah i feel like i just have to
trust people as friends first and then
you kind of build them there uh maybe
flirty but
i would say a flaw is
that i'm like all in or not in it at all
cash app your date twenty dollars oh wow
i love this game now sure i got you
perfect
are you sure david's like 200 let me say
that my phone's dead
down play
anybody
i like this so far if you want to add a
little note don't be saying you gotta
change you gotta you know shift savings
to the check-ins just pay it out oh my
gosh this is hilarious i ain't even
gonna know you yet for real you already
got twenty dollars out of it
twenty dollars that's like
two gallons of gas with inflation that's
just a dinner you know nothing too crazy
22 because it's like cash up etiquette
you know what i mean
[Music]
he's like i got money money
you just got a major
there we appointment
they did a good job of picking people on
like similar attractive levels like
they're both in shape both
oh my gosh this guy i got a crush on you
sir oh my goodness thank you you're
welcome spend it well i'll do it there
it better not be no more money let your
date choose your dare
what about like five push-ups you got
this
that's such a lame dare five push-ups
five yes
what's up
craig
go ahead and run me that 20 back
honestly i'm not even mad at you because
i probably would have did the same thing
whispering my ear the freakiest thing
you've ever done to a girl oh my
okay see okay i'm a real tahitian like
vanilla type of guy you know
i don't know how i feel
like i keep it simple but like there's
there's some flair to it
yeah but so babe yeah you know dash
let your date choose your truth
okay it's getting spicy so you get to
choose any question where's the last
time you cried
last week i was watching a journal for
jordan that's very cute
it was
when was your last relationship
my last relationship was what's the best
answer to this question i was thinking
about this because
when you ask someone that
if they're like a month ago you're like
it's a little soon you know
i think the best answer as long as it
wasn't like a
it wasn't like a three four five year
relationship is like six months
now
if it was a super long relationship i
would say a year is a good answer wow
what do you guys think let me know in
the chat
okay can you sing i can sing it it
doesn't mean i can sing well but i can
sing saying you got it bad by oh sure
that's like my karaoke i don't
i don't think they're vibing this couple
i think the other two couples are like
vibe and vibing but the guy's kind of
awkward
like do you see their body language
all right stop stop record deal
rate your own sex and tell your opponent
why
a month is too soon like after because
you don't want someone that's still like
hung up on their ex
so if it's been a month since their last
relationship
and that kind of soon they dated for a
while
most relationships are at least a couple
months
what planet do you live on sir i'm you
know i'm a tourist i'm a 10 you know
i feel like i know what i'm doing
good size
a lot of experience
expeditious
not that i can think of off the top of
my head hasn't just been a one-off
yeah what's going on no towels in here
that was a nice crack
oh she's funny
she's funny
give your date three compliments
i like your smile
i'm really in love with dimples i didn't
say that before but because i knew that
you were going to smile and show off
your dimples
i have those too you like buff
you look like
you be in a gym yeah
i like that just a little bit yeah
you have a good personality honestly i
think everything about you is really
great i love
your style
oh no sir oh no i also love your curves
thank you and i do love your skin i
really like the sound of your voice
it is like
very
handsome sexy i don't know how to say it
you have like a little accent too the
shape of your face is gorgeous thank you
and you have a really nice smile
and you got little freckles that's cute
okay you actually got four thank you i
appreciate that
you'd say heel for a week then it's fair
game
look at it i think if a guy just broke
up with a girlfriend of a while
he's probably not over her in a month
and vice versa
yeah
i you must not have dated a lot of
people let me know in the chat if that's
just me
respectfully you know what i mean like
respectfully of one to ten overall i
think you're a nine like personality
everything it's on ten she's saying that
to be nice she doesn't mean it i can
just tell easy to talk to
thank
also it helps if you go out
and
hook up with someone
it's like a catalyst for healing after a
breakup i don't think so
i'm not doing music reactions live they
keep getting taken down um and copyright
struck sorry
i give you a 10 sir slide in my dms oh
my god so looks wise i'm an 8.5 i don't
know if we're just going off the left i
think it'd be like a 9.5 okay cool
that's bad i wasn't sure i don't really
know you cool yeah that's fair that's
valid after which date is it cool to go
to third base what is third base
is that like oral well okay so i have
two rules for this
i don't really give to guys that aren't
like my guy guy yes because that's nasty
and i don't know where you've been two i
don't give unless i'm receiving so i
have like two guidelines to that rule so
i don't really know what date that would
be that would probably be
a couple dates down the line okay so
like
pearl needs a date hey hey
i do
i do
yeah okay
as long as we're concentrating yeah yeah
absolutely it's completely cool
completely cool uh what about home run
i don't know what date that could fall
under a couple tequila shots and it's a
wrap let your date read your dms allow
oh my gosh y'all know y'all wrong as
hell buddy oh my god i would rather die
i'm bold than the dms oh i'm bold
my phone died your phone died yeah i
think you have a chorus somewhere okay
let me see come on
the dms
okay love it
somebody said uh come on baby thank you
angel
that is so funny
you can tell these men are like no
no
same person and energy since the first
time we met thank you all right awesome
right yeah hella memes i can't read
memes hey happy new year to you as well
all as well just grinding per usual
what's goodie with you
where's all the good stuff come on man
where are the titties at
is flirting while in a relationship
cheating i think it is cheating what do
you guys think
and don't give me some nonsense like oh
it is for women but not for me like
why not
yes
big answer yes it is a form of cheating
um